What is Twinmotion and who is it for?
Great question.
It's actually a very easy to use real time environment
in which you can use a tool to create your ideas
and communicate those quickly
and iterate them through various clients.
Now it gives the user the ability
to quickly and easily build your scenes
and what I referred to earlier
as a WYSIWYG type environment
in which you can drag and drop
directly into your scene, affecting it immediately.
Lots of other great tools exist within Twinmotion
but we won't be going over those today.
However, what we will be giving you
as a great overview of what you can do
and get you started so you can take off
and really learn it.
So who is it for exactly?
Well, originally Twinmotion was designed
for architect in mind only.
However, it has branched off as you can see
from AEC, automotive, media and entertainment,
products and retail, as well as fashion.
So it's just not for AEC anymore.